madame antho bonsoir bienvenue à 24,60
bonsoir et félicitations pour ce prix
renaudot reçu avec grande surprise et
grand étonnement de votre part n'est ce
pas vous ne vous y attendiez pas puisque
vous n'étiez pas sur la liste des
finalistes et votre nom votre oeuvre a
ressurgi comment l'avez-vous accueilli
exactement passé accueilli d'abord comme
une blague
sincèrement j'ai c'est vrai que j'étais
sorti de la liste des finalistes donc je
ne m'attendais pas du tout à ce qu'on
appelle donc un quart d'heure avant mon
éditeur m'a appelé j'étais à marseille
donc je n'habite même pas à paris pour
me dire que j'avais gagné le renaudot
j'ai d'abord cru qu'il me faisait une
blague vraiment très sincèrement je le
dis je vais attendre que ça soit annoncé
à la radio pour y croire et donc voilà
j'ai attendu patiemment jusqu'à 13
heures l'annoncé officielle pour prendre
un train et venir arroser ça au
champagne avec mes collègues c'était
vraiment c'était une super surprise
alors commençons par le commencement si
vous voulez bien valais un manteau le
titre le sillon d'ailleurs vous dédié le
sillon et je vous souhaite de vous même
et dédiée à sedan l'absence et le
souvenir résonne entre céline pourquoi
ce titre
le sillon d'abord ça la traduction d'un
titre de titre d'un journal turc puisque
le livre ce pas sentir qu'ils racontent
une années que j'ai passées en turquie
le sillon en turquie et en arménien il
ya un mot qui veut dire le sillon qui
est à gauche et c'est le titre d'un
journal qui existe encore aujourd'hui
qui est dédié à la coexistence pacifique
des minorités en turquie et notamment à
la minorité arménienne
je pense que tout le monde sait par chez
nous par chez vous qu'il ya eu un
génocide arménien en turquie mais en
turquie et le négationnisme continuez
donc ce journal essayait de faire
prendre conscience à la population
turque de l'histoire de la minorité
arménienne en turquie et son directeur
jean dink a été assassiné en 2007 au
pied de son journal pour avoir défendu
cet idéal de paix de la communion
des communautés en turquie et moi j'ai
découvert cette histoire un peu par
hasard en 2015 après les attentats de
charlie hebdo et j'ai voulu raconter
cette histoire parce que j'avais
beaucoup de proximité avec l'histoire de
charlie me semblait-il et que pour moi
qui avais vécu de très près les
attentats de charlie c'était un fils
intéressant a déroulé donc voila c'était
ça le début de l'histoire
par ailleurs le sillon pour une oreille
française en tout cas c'est un mot qui
évoque l'hymne national nous dans la
marseillaise on a fait ce ver qui est
d'ailleurs le plus problématique de la
marseillaise qui est qu'un sang impur
abreuve nos sillons et c'est vrai que
alors en plus du fait que c'était le
titre du journal de rentes pour moi je
trouvais que d'avoir donné ce titre là
un journal pour quelqu'un qui avait été
assassiné par nationalistes s'étaient
tristement ironique ça disait des choses
c'était une façon de parler aussi de
nationalisme pas que en turquie ce que
ça ne concerne pas que la turquie de le
ramener aussi à l'échelle française à
l'échelle européenne de dire ça ne se
passe pas que dans cet orient compliqué
orientalisée ça nous concerne aussi là
je crois que c'est ça le le début de
l'histoire de ce livre
oui parce que ce journaliste a été
assassiné après avoir été maintes fois
menacé a invité même à partir il ne
voulait pas céder à la peur vous le
décrivez très bien il ya même la
métaphore des colombes et se décrivait
comme un oiseau inquiet oui c'est là une
des choses les plus bouleversants de son
histoire vraiment cet homme a d'abord
une histoire très romanesque que je
raconte par petites bribes dans le livre
mais c'était un orphelin quelqu'un qui a
grandi à l'orphelinat qui est devenu
directeur d'orphelinats qu'ensuite a
créé une maison d'édition une librairie
un journal qui est parti de rien et qui
est devenu cette cible exposé à la rage
des nationalismes et dans le dernier
éditorial qu'il a publié le jour de sa
mort il parlait de son état
d'inquiétudes face aux menaces qu'il
recevait tous les jours et il disait
qu'il vivait dans la peau d'une colombe
enfin une colombe ou un pigeon passe
quand sûrs que les deux mots sont
quasiment les mains
enfin le même mot devine les deux
oiseaux et mais bon la plupart du temps
on traduit par colombe il dit je suis et
je vienne dans l'inquiétude d'une
colombe au milieu des villas toujours me
demander à me retourner regarder
derrière sur le côté devant à me
demander qui pourrait jeter la première
pierre
et il finissait sur une sorte de notes
d'espoir en dix ans mais je sais que
dans ce pays on ne fait pas de mal aux
oiseaux et il a été assassiné le jour
même de la publication de cet article
ouais c'est une chose parmi d'autres
mais à laquelle je me suis est relié de
l'histoire très émouvante de cet homme
là on a découvert au hasard donc et on
peut aussi faire le lien avec le titre
le sillon vous même vous vous inscrivez
dans ce sillon de cette créé par la
violence des attentats vous avez vécu
charlie hebdo de parce que vous y avez
perdu des proches vous avez été dans le
passé éditrice de charlie hebdo et donc
vous il ya eu on est à la veille du
bataclan on est à la veille de
l'armistice on est à la veille en une
conjoncture qui nous rend ce livre son
roman absolument passionnant est aussi
inquiétant est-ce vous qui le dites ou
sedin qui le dit aussi
la population sur qui ne veut pas vivre
payer justement des colons de
l'assassiner mais personne ne veut vivre
dans un pays de colomb assassiner les
turcs pas plus que nous c'est vrai que
la turquie encore plus que la france a
été victime d'attentats ces dernières
années ravageurs attentats islamistes
alors c'est vrai que moi j'ai perdu des
proches dans l'attentât de charlie ça
m'a rendu très réceptive à cette
histoire et au drame que vit la turquie
aujourd'hui qui est au premier rang des
attentats il y en a eu beaucoup plus il
ya eu beaucoup plus de morts en turquie
qu'en france qu'on a parfois un peu de
mal
on ne réalise mal quand quand on a des
attentats en plein coeur de paris que
les pays les premiers exposés sont les
pays musulmans
en termes de nombre de morts mais moi je
trouvais que justement le l'empathie et
le transfert d'un pays à l'autre moi m'a
fait beaucoup de bien de comprendre que
c'était pas à une guerre de civilisation
pas en tout cas pays contre pays
c'est une guerre contre un certain mode
de vie dans nos pays et que en turquie
moi c'est ce que j'ai voulu raconter
aussi dans ce livre la vie de la
jeunesse qui veut ou de la jeunesse et
de tous les âges d'ailleurs qui veulent
vivre pacifiquement qui veulent aller au
théâtre qui veulent lire des livres qui
veulent aller boire des verres
alcoolisées ou pas manger ou ne pas
manger pendant le ramadan cette ville à
l'existant istanbul elle essaye de
subsister et elle est mise sous pression
elles et moi j'ai voulu raconter la
survie de ce mode de vie là à istanbul
dans le contexte aujourd'hui la survie
de ce mode de vue de ceux villa à
l'européenne et à la manière turc imposé
par air dorante parce que vous allez
quotidiennement ou presque entre la rive
européenne la rive asiatique
vous avez vous raconter cette ce
tabassage de à l'occasion du ramadan
justement parce qu'on boit de la bière
les jeunes se rassemblent et cette peur
qui croît au fil des pages parce que
vous êtes témoin en 2016
au moment même où nice se produit
d'ailleurs en attente à nice en juillet
le 14 juillet est arrivé le même jour
que la tentative de coup d'état
et vous décrivez presque et créant chez
nous une certaine frayeur une peur de
cette répression la tyrannie
l'étouffement la démocratie s'installe
de en turquie avec air douanes je pense
qu'en turquie est l'un des plus gros
problèmes de la turquie c'est son
emplacement stratégique inédite ils
vivent à l'européenne mais vivent
vraiment à la turquie à istanbul
c'est un mode de vie très particulier
qui est à l'image de ce pays qui est la
plaque tournante de tout ce qui se passe
en ce moment et les feux sont croisés
sur la turquie jeudi je compare pas
vraiment la veste situation de des
autres pays occidentaux avec la turquie
parce que c'est pire en turquie il y a
le les attentats terroristes que nous
avons aussi connu en france mais la
situation politique depuis le virage des
douanes
des croix de plus en plus catastrophique
de jour en jour et c'est vrai que
l'année 2016 que moi j'ai passé en
turquie on alternait les nouvelles entre
eux les attentats terroristes les crises
diplomatiques entre la russie et la
turquie par exemple le la tentative de
coup d'état
c'est vrai qu'il se passait pas un jour
sans des nouvelles de plus en plus
catastrophique on a l'impression d'être
en première ligne quand on est en
turquie
on est en première ligne mais ça veut
pas dire que nous autres nous ne sommes
pas en seconde ligne
mais c'est vrai que là bas les choses
sont plus effrayante parce que elles
sont beaucoup plus immédiate mais vous
vous demandez à un moment après la
tentative de coup d'état
pardon on a vécu cet effondrement très
particulier quasiment sous nos yeux
visible jour après jour de ce que de
l'état de droit
erdogan a littéralement détruit l'état
dort en turquie il n'y a plus de justice
on apprenait tous les jours des
arrestations des motifs d'accusation
plus grotesque que les uns que les
autres et ça ça continue par là il ya
vraiment une situation très particulière
cela dit la montée des populistes et des
abymes d'habillement de la démocratie ça
concerne malheureusement de plus en plus
de pays on le voit bien la montée des
populistes en europe aux etats-unis au
brésil maintenant enfin on compte plus
les pays maintenant qu'ils sont sur des
pentes glissantes cas pas dire pire
valérie manteau nous parlions des
populismes qui monte
on vient de vivre au coeur même de la
turquie un drame géopolitique très
important est ce que vous seriez capable
de faire un lien entre ce qui se passe
avec la sphère khashoggi par exemple le
fait qu'ils voilà ce journaliste qui a
été assassiné au consulat saoudien en
turquie avec la turquie qui dénonce le
traitement qui lui a été réservé alors
qu'il y a tellement de journalistes
emprisonnés en ce moment même en turquie
vu de marseille où vous travaillez vous
vivez comment voyez-vous la chose évolué
avec beaucoup d'ironie malheureusement
je trouve que on le drame de
l'assassinât de deux
de ce journaliste à istambul donne la
possibilité à erdogan de se séparer de
cette image de défenseur de la presse
dont qui équipe qui devrait jouer
simplement faire tristement sourire
vraiment ya des centaines de
journalistes qui ont été arrêtés des
dizaines de médias qui ont été fermés
dès l'assassinât de hrant dink n'est pas
du tout un cas isolé dans l'histoire de
la turquie et des journalistes
assassinés
il y en a des dizaines de ces dernières
années en turquie
et la complicité des meurtriers de
rentes n'a toujours pas été élucidé et
très probablement remonter jusqu'en haut
de l'état donc je pense que là vraiment
il faut me prêter une oreille très
critique à ce que air doit ne peut bien
avoir à nous dire sur la liberté le soin
qu'il faut prendre de la vie des
journalistes par ce livre le sillon vous
redonner la parole à reading vous
redonner la parole
cette romancière asli erdogan vous
redonner la parole aussi à des
dissidents des gens qui réclament cette
liberté d'expression vous allez
peut-être retourner en turquie bientôt
pour on comprend votre amour pour
istanbul
est ce que vous êtes vous même un oiseau
inquiet est ce que vous risquez gros en
retourne en turquie puisque vous donner
la parole à ces gens là vous les fait
revivre au fond j'essaye j'essaie j'ai
essayé dans ce livre de prendre le
relais justement de alors deux personnes
qui ne peuvent plus parler parce
qu'elles ont été assassinés ou qu'on
essaye de faire taire come as you are
douane comme d'autres gens mais je me
i'll pie x latine de mire tâche qui est
aujourd'hui en prison à remettre altan
merveilleuse écrivain grand journaliste
qui est aujourd'hui en prison
évidemment moi je me suis dit que on
essaie de faire taire ces gens et que
notre rôle à nous chacun dans notre
place mais à moi qui écris c'est de
venir relayer leurs paroles je le fais
aussi avec une beaucoup plus grande
sécurité que évidemment c'est une façon
de ne pas les laisser en première ligne
puisque eux peuvent être arrêter du jour
au lendemain et l'on est et peuvent être
condamnés sous des motifs complètement
grotesque armes et à l'aneth ans a été
condamné à perpétuité pour avoir envoyé
des messages subliminaux à la télévision
quand même ça le la chose qui lui est
reproché moi je suis inquiète pour eux
surtout je suis pas inquiète pour moi je
on peut pas tellement savoir c'est
difficile de savoir ce qu'on risque
quand la justice n'a plus trop de sens
et quand les règles du droit ne sont pas
respectées cela dit j'ai conscience
d'être relativement protégé par rapport
à tous ces gens donc le notre
responsabilité
elle est aussi de de prendre ce risque
vous suivez le chef dirige retournerai
en turquie enfin jusqu'à ce qu'on me
dise le contraire j'y retournerais vous
citez le chef de l'opposition au moment
des tentatives de putsch vous vous
faites vous êtes aussi peut-être que les
mêmes les anti air douanes n'aurait pas
nécessairement souhaité la prise du
pouvoir par les putschistes mais en
citant le chef de le pouce de partis
d'opposition vous dites vouloir la paix
c'est un délit en turquie et insulté la
turquie le fait est qu'il a été arrêté
juste après avoir dit ça et qu'il est
aujourd'hui en prison ils risquent cent
quarante deux ans de prison sa ligne de
mire tâche pour participation à une
entreprise terroriste
moi j'ai des amis on connaît tous enfin
les gens qui travaillent en turquie les
universitaires qui ont signé cette
pétition pour la paix au kurdistan sont
aujourd'hui inculpé pour propagande
terroriste voire pour participation à
une entreprise terroriste
donc littéralement appelé à la paix dans
ce pays aujourd'hui est un crime c'est
un problème de niveau abyssal bien le
style il n'y a plus de droit
il n'y a plus de droit et dans une scène
président veut faire contre ça l'est un
peu écrire peut-être prendre la plume un
creuser davantage le sillon pas de la
parole par le roman vous étiez dans une
scène assez émouvante y en a plusieurs
dans le livre vous allez vous aller
retracer la tombe de rands inc et vous
vous y présenter avec des murs en fin dé
sur des sandales bon tout simplement pin
jupe très courte que vous vous demandez
à un moment donné si vous pouvez
toujours vous promener en turquie avec
une robe courte vêtu à l'occidentale
c'est pour bien illustrer le dans le
fond la transformation de cette société
parce que vous décrivez aussi
l'omniprésence des femmes voilées
vêtu de noir évidemment là avec sans
doute le niqab et d'autres vêtements de
très très éloquent non c'est un peu plus
compliqué avec ça c'est à dire que le
personnage de la narratrice est encore
plus ingénieux que moi je dirais et
istanbul c'est une ville très diverses
d'un quartier à l'autre poule et la
population change et la façon de
s'habiller change aussi beaucoup et
c'est vrai que moi j'habitais dans le
même quartier que là où j'ai placé le
roman c'est à dire acadie kite est un
quartier très multiculturelle très
ouvert où pendant l'été dans laquelle je
raconte cette scène les femmes sont la
plupart des femmes sont en jupe en
minijupe ya très peu de femmes voilées à
cali cueille mellac tombe de landing et
dans un quartier beaucoup plus
conservateurs se sont laissé l'ancien
quartier arménien mais aujourd'hui il ya
peu de quasiment plus d'armes entre
istanbul et c'est un quartier où se sont
installés les nouvelles minorité de
de la ville et notamment beaucoup de
syriens de syrienne et les femmes
syriennes sont beaucoup plus
conservatrice que les turcs et sont très
souvent voilées et c'est pour ça que
quand j'ai des places emma narratrice
jusqu'à la tombe de nantes
elle change de quartier et elle se
retrouve en sortant du tramway dans ce
quartier conservateur il fait 40 degrés
elle est aux robes en tongs ce qui ne
pose aucun problème
elle n'a d'ailleurs aucun problème et
moi je n'en ai jamais eu à istanbul à
titre personnel mais elle se retrouve
d'un coup au milieu de femmes tout en
noir comme il y en a aussi beaucoup dans
certains quartiers elle se retrouve à
aller demander aller aux policiers son
chemin pour aller jusqu'à la tombe de
lente dont on sait que la police a
probablement était complice de son
assassinat
et donc elle se demande effectivement
c'est plus un questionnement sur sa
propre ingéniosité quelques
questionnements sur le changement de la
turquie c'est à dire jusqu'à quel point
on quand on est étranger on met les
pieds dans le plat
est ce qu'on est en train d'être naïfs
ou est-ce que simplement on est en train
de découvrir une nouvelle culture mois
cette question là elle m'a beaucoup
intéressé en tant qu'étrangère dans ce
pays qui est très complexe
en terminant vous déploriez eu des
manifestations en 2007 au moment de la
mort de ce journaliste que vous nous
faites connaître un grand dink il n'y a
pas eu quelques manifestations mais pas
celle qu'on a connue au lendemain de de
charlie on a vu je suis charlie
aujourd'hui avec l'évolution le
populisme la montée de la droite les
attaques puisque dink était décrit comme
un ennemi public
l'ennemi du peuple dans dans les
circonstances que vous décrivez
aujourd'hui on entend trump à dire que
les journées sont les ennemis du peuple
sont avait à dire quelque chose je suis
charlie est ce que ça tient la route
encore qu'est ce qu'on serait
aujourd'hui je pense que je suis charlie
la force du slogan je suis charlie moi
ce qui m'intéresse le début dans cette
histoire c'est de découvrir que allah
l'enterrement de dink les turcs sont
sortis dans la rue et il ya eu une
manifestion énorme des centaines de
milliers de personnes au slogan de nous
sommes tous arméniens et pour moi nous
sommes tous arméniens c'est aussi fort
que nous sommes tous charlie ça veut
dire nous font nous faisons front avec
les cibles vous voulez cibler les
arméniens mais nous sommes tous
arméniens
vous avez voulu cibler charlie et les
gens sont sortis dans la rue en disant
si vous voulez tuer charlie vous devrez
nous tuer nous tous et il y avait quatre
millions de personnes dans la rue en
france et des gens des manifestations
dans le monde entier
moi je pense que la force de cette idée
là papa de charlie en tant que tel de la
force du slogan je suis charlie elle est
immense elle et de dire nous faisons
front ensemble
moi je vois pas il n'y a pas de slogan
kia qui a autant de force aujourd'hui il
faut utiliser celui là je pense est
inutilisé ça ça immensément de sens
évidemment est ce que ce que trump
incarne à la face du monde en ce moment
et terrifiant valérie aimard tous merci
nous avons accordé cet entretien
continuer de célébrer ce prix renaudot
et certains parlent de votre livre comme
a bien sûr un roman mais certains y
ajoutent elles
la force d'un grand reportage d'un
document on y retrouve beaucoup
d'émotion beaucoup d'informations et il
est absolument passionnant on le dévore
merci beaucoup je vous remercie beaucoup
merci